today on the Matt Walsh show two ER
doctors committed the sin of criticizing
the lockdowns and pointing out that
there are counter-productive and in fact
do not help with public health but
actually make the situation worse their
video that went viral explaining all
this was removed from YouTube because of
it and so we'll talk about the effort to
censor anyone who doesn't total RT line
on the corona virus this is not the only
example of that also five headlines
including newly released footage of
alien spacecraft could be maybe
something else but we're gonna go with
alien spacecraft and the Washington Post
is twisting itself into knots to avoid
just honestly and directly reporting on
the Biden sex assault allegations the
story is getting big enough in spite of
the mainstream media that they have to
at least acknowledge it but the way
they're going about doing that is
outrageous also hilarious and in our
daily cancellation I must once again
cancel someone very close to me I hate
to do it but it must be done and all of
that is coming up but first a word from
books you know Mother's Day just so you
know is only a few days away in case you
forgot and you are not off the hook for
Mother's Day Mother's Day is not shut
down everything else might be shut down
but Mother's Day is not so you better
figure out a way to get your kid to get
a present to your mother and that's
where books can help you
you can't give mom a hug but you can
send flowers from the books company
books that's short for bouquets by the
way books are responsibly sourced from
some of the world's finest eco-friendly
farms even farms on the sides of
volcanoes you can give your mom volcano
flowers alright so flowers stay fresher
longer
did you know flowers and plants have
been proven to reduce stress and boost
productivity now that or send it we're
spending more time at home how about a
little self-love to brighten your day
and your space big savings mean you can
send farm fresh flowers plants and gift
bundles to all the moms in your lives
your mom a soon-to-be mom your wife your
grandma a dog mom or treat or you know I
personally I wouldn't be setting I mean
I think you have to personally my view
is you got to have a human child the
counters mom but that's just me or are
you going to treat yourself to you know
how about sent flowers to yourself send
smiles no matter no matter the miles
with books
dot-com / Walsh that's B o u q s comm /
Walsh and enter code walls for 25% off
your entire order again that's code
walls for 25% off at bucks comm / Walsh
okay so when they're when they're
censoring you you know that you're
probably on to something emergency room
doctors Dan Eriksen and Artin Massa he
in California they did a press briefing
a few days ago discussing Cova 19 and
making a case that the lock downs are
unnecessary counterproductive actually
worse for Public Health so it's not just
about and this is a point that's
probably not emphasized enough you know
most of us who have criticized a
lockdown so we've been focusing on the
economic damage and for good reason but
I think sometimes we're sort of
implicitly ceding the case on the health
aspect of it and it's like we're saying
that yeah well the lock downs are they
may keep you healthier but then you got
to compare that to the economic
devastation well but there actually
that's that's not a point that we should
surrender it is by no means obvious that
this was the best thing to do for Public
Health and that's part of the point that
these doctors were making the video of
that briefing went viral on YouTube and
then they were on Fox News last night
they're all with Laura Ingraham last
night and almost immediately after that
we discovered that YouTube has removed
the video took it down for violating
guidelines now first let me read a
little bit about this video since I
can't play it reading from The Daily
wire.com says during a press conference
on Wednesday California emergency room
doctors Dan Erickson Dan Erickson and
Arden Massa he of accelerated Urgent
Care told reporters that nationwide
lockdown policies are not an appropriate
reaction to what current data shows
about the China originated novel
coronavirus but are instead causing
measurable public health issues like
spikes and domestic violence sexual
abuse depression spreading fear tune
ANCOVA 19 related would be patients that
are skipping out on vital health care
the
Erikson said quote we understand
microbiology we understand immune
analogy and we want strong immune
systems I don't want to stay in my home
and develop a weak immune system and
then come out and get a disease Erikson
noted that quarantine the healthy is
like nothing he's seen before we decided
to keep people at home and isolate them
even though everything we've studied
about quarantine typically you
quarantine the sick when someone has
measles you quarantine them we've never
seen the healthy where you take these
those without disease and without
symptoms and lock them in your own some
of these things come from what we've
studied from immunology and microbiology
aren't really meshing with what we know
as people of scientific minds who read
this stuff he goes on and says when I
talk to ER physicians around the country
what's happening well because Co vyd has
become the focus people with heart
disease people with cancer hypertension
various things that are critical are
choosing not to come in based on fear so
what that's doing is forcing the
healthcare system to focus on Co vyd and
not focus on a myriad of other things
that are critical because we don't have
the staff there and major and the major
complaint is fear and there's a lot okay
there's a lot more to it but if you go
to youtube to find this video now this
is what you're gonna see instead the
video violates Community Guidelines and
YouTube is not the only website doing
this kind of censoring Facebook has been
deleting Facebook event pages for
lockdown protests if you try to organize
a protest on Facebook they might delete
it and a spokesman for Facebook said he
was asked about this said quote events
that defy government's guidance on
social distancing aren't allowed on
Facebook so protests that defy the
government aren't allowed now call me
crazy but I'd say that defying the
government is sort of the point of a
protest isn't it that's sort of the
whole idea as I've been saying for a
while we have to be prepared for this
kind of thing there's gonna be a lot
more of it as
more and more data comes out especially
these antibody tests showing that that
this this disease is far wider spread
than what we were told which means that
it's far less deadly than we were told
and it also means that you know the cat
was out of the bag a long time ago and
this thing had already spread through
many communities and then we lock down
after the fact which makes it and that's
the point that dr. Erickson was making
that makes it worse than unnecessary
I mean unnecessary in and of itself is
catastrophic considering you're doing
something unnecessary and the price is
destroying the economy and millions of
lives along with it but it's worse than
that it's counterproductive so as this
as this all becomes clearer that's going
to mean that the government officials
responsible for this it will be revealed
it will be made clear that those
officials responsible for the lockdown
are therefore responsible for as I've
been saying and I think this is not
hyperbole possibly the worst
governmental blunder in American history
I can't think of anything else quite
like this a policy like this that just
embraces a Great Depression destroying
your own economy on purpose in such a
direct way now there have been huge
mistakes made in the past that had that
had devastating effects of course the
government's done that many times but
there's never been anything quite like
this to go from what was it 3%
unemployment or something along those
lines before the lockdowns and in the
span of a month or month and a half
we're at you know 16 17 18 percent when
the unemployment numbers come out on
Thursday it's gonna be over 30 million
unemployed so the government putting 30
million people out of a job in like a
month I can't think of any other time
when something like that's happened and
it has
happen as dr. Erickson pointed out it
didn't happen back when we had other
this is not the first disease we've ever
dealt with it is not the first pandemic
we've ever dealt with it is the first
time though that we decided to lock tens
of millions hundreds of millions of
healthy people in their home for homes
for weeks at a time and that's why using
the word quarantine that's not the right
word it's not a quarantine it's a house
arrest quarantine is what you do in fact
isolation is for a sick person
quarantine is for someone who you know
has been exposed to a disease it is not
something that you impose on entire
populations of people if you do that
it's not a quarantine its house arrest
so what's what what are these government
officials gonna do are they gonna have
moral courage to come out and admit hey
we really botched this one we got it
wrong
our bad sorry about that no I mean
they're gonna they're gonna they're
gonna go down swinging there the entire
time they're going to claim that this
was the right thing and they're probably
gonna get even more aggressive in
censoring and shutting down people who
point out the opposite one thing we have
to understand here about about the
lockdowns you know there's a lot of
conspiracy theories and everything susan
it's not a conspiracy what this was it
but it also wasn't about saving lives I
don't think it but it also wasn't you
know it's clear to me that these
government officials their primary
concern was not saving lives I also
don't think that they were all
conspiring and getting together and
saying let's just let's destroy the
economy to stop Trump from being
reelected that theory doesn't work
either and I'll tell you one of the
reasons that theory doesn't work is
because Trump has been on board with
this himself so unless he was trying to
destroy the economy to it to ruin his
own election chances to sabotage himself
then I don't see that know what it was
something more simple in that this is
just one elaborate wide-ranging cya
opera
you know cya cover your ass and that's
what these all these governor's and
politicians and people in the federal
government health care experts and so on
they're they just were covering their
own asses
trying to do what was safest for them
not for you but for them they were
thinking was a political this was a
political calculation made by a bunch of
self-interested moral cowards it's as
simple as that and this is where it
leads I want to tell you about speaking
of things that are very simple I want to
tell you about our friends at beard
supply know a beard is something that is
very simple and also essential okay we
talk about essential workers well this
is essential if you're a man you got to
have a beard but if you have the beard
you got to take care of it have some
pride have some dignity for God's sakes
you thought you know maybe if you some
people are trying the new beard right
now they're trying out new beard looks
because they're in quarantine maybe you
thought quarantine was your chance to
try something new to let down your
facial hair and join the ranks of your
bearded brethren well you must have
missed the memo because a beard isn't
just fun and games all right it's not
some fifth-grade science experiment with
Mentos and soda it is sacred art this is
serious business and beard Supply is
leading you to the promised land by now
you've discovered that a full healthy
beard isn't just something you can order
on Amazon Prime more often than not your
beard is gonna be dry itchy patchy and
at its worst as sparse as a face Mac
face mask aisle at the hardware store
now this is this is you know you you
think it's just you can just you can
just dive in and grow beard and what you
discover is that it's harder than that
you've got to take care of them you got
to nourish them nurture them train them
educate them and that's why you need
beard supply for a limited time beard
supply is offering my listeners 25% off
go-to beard supply.com and use promo
code walls for 25% off all oil soaps
balms and grooming supplies
that's beard supply.com promo code Walsh
your beard can be so much better let's
be honest so go to beard supply.com
today all right let's move on to
headlines and we'll start with this the
biggest story of the century the united
states government has announced
officially that aliens do exist and they
visited us maybe not exactly I'm
paraphrasing and they didn't announce
that officially but they did release
some footage of UFOs these are
previously top-secret videos taken by
Navy pilots and I don't know you judge
for yourself there it is confirmation
okay there is literally nothing else
that could be except a lian's no other
explanation is possible at least no
other explanation is as interesting and
exciting as aliens and so I just go yeah
that's the thing if you're a rational
person you always choose and if you're
someone who believes in philosophical
rigor you're always going to go with the
more fascinating and interesting
explanation all right
of course actually I've as I've said
many times I think unfortunately aliens
do exist but they're never gonna be here
I was talking to somebody recently and
they were saying they were saying hey
there you know the universe is so big
there could be a hundred billion other
intelligent civilizations out there yeah
there could be but you know what if
there was a hundred billion telogen
civilizations guess what that's one per
galaxy do you know how long it would
take to get from one galaxy to another
even if you're going the speed of light
you're talking millions of years so it's
just they're never gonna be here
although they're out there you can go
out it you can go out at night and wave
to them maybe they can see you with
their really fancy telescopes but I
don't think they're ever gonna come here
unfortunately so those were probably
just drones hate to say speaking of
alien creatures here's a Joe Biden on
CBS yesterday I would get much more
engaged in the world we can't step back
if in fact for example we solve the
problem in the United States America and
you don't solve it other parts of the
world you know what's gonna happen we're
gonna have you're gonna have travel bans
you're gonna not be able to do have have
economic intercourse around the world
there's a lot look when America goes
alone when America's first it's America
alone economic intercourse closet
economic intercourse the thing that Joe
Biden does you and you can tell when
he's speaking and giving an
answer at an interview or at a debate
you know he's you could tell he's
putting a lot of effort he's trying
really hard to come across like he knows
what he's talking about and he's lucid
he's making a scene he does this with
his hands and that's how you know these
really trying to Zone in and focus but
it all comes apart I mean he can't speak
for more than 15 seconds without
divulging into incoherence and you know
I play that because it's it's kind of
funny but I'm getting at the point where
I can hardly even laugh at it anymore
because it really is just sad and
pitiful and you have to think the people
closest and the people in his life his
wife his family his closest advisors
what are they doing dragging this guy
out onstage I mean they need to sit him
down and say and we got to pull the plug
on this they have to step up because the
person they're supposed to care about is
falling apart in front of the entire
world and and in you know many people if
you live long enough you're gonna start
to lose your mental faculties everybody
does and lots of people when they get to
Joe Biden's age get dementia you know
it's it's a it's a really common thing
in fact once you get this is my whole
reason why I've said we shouldn't be
there needs to be an upper age limit on
the presidency it's it's crazy to me
that there isn't if there's a lower age
limit there ought to be an upper age
limit
I say 75 you know 35 is the lower limit
75 is the upper limit that gives you a
solid 40 years if you want to become
president you got 40 years to do it if
you can't do it in 40 years then I would
say you had your shot and why don't you
just go and sit on the rocking chair on
your porch and talk to your grandkids so
because once you get to 80 you're your
chance at 80 you know your chance of
developing dementia I think is like
something like 20% it's significant and
of course as you get older it becomes
even more significant so this is
something that many people have gone
through it's very sad it's just that
most people don't go through it on in
front of the entire world on
television let's see number three here's
an incredible headline from the
Washington Post
take a look it says developments in
allegations against Biden amplify
efforts to question his behavior at
first blush that just seems like a bunch
of words where we're thrown in a blender
and then poured out onto the onto the
page doesn't even seem to make sense but
you look again developments and
allegations against Biden amplify
efforts to question his behavior
now I remind you this is a headline in
the Washington Post this is not
something from a press release written
by Biden's lawyers that you would think
that Biden's lawyers wrote this headline
and maybe in fact they did and then they
change the headline on the actual
article and made it even worse so here's
the new headline on the article itself
it says Trump allies highlight new
claims regarding allegations against
Biden let's say what that makes that
even worse is that they're it's Trump
allies so everybody who is pointing out
that Joe Biden was accused of rape
credibly is a trump ally now even though
Tara Reid herself is a Democrat she is
not a trump ally and she's the one
making the accusation which is yet
another thing in fact I was listing all
the differences between the Tara Reid
and Christine Ford yesterday and talking
about how much more credible these
allegations are whether you think these
allegations are credible or not they're
certainly much more credible than
Christine Ford's allegation one one
factor I forgot to point out is that on
top of the fact that Tara Reid actually
has some circumstantial evidence she can
produce whereas Christine Ford had none
also the politics of the Christine Ford
was an open left-wing liberal you know
very much against Cavanaugh's politics
or what are perceived to be his politics
so you could see how there'd be an extra
incentive there to embellish or
exaggerate or lie fabricate but with
Tara Reid she's a Democrat so there's
not any immediately obvious political
motivation here
and in any case oh that's that's that's
the way that the Washington Post is
framing it there's just obviously I
don't think I have to explain what's
wrong with this and how much different
this headline would be if Biden was a
Republican but just to focus on one
aspect of this efforts to question his
behavior what a very odd way of talking
about a rape allegation so if you allege
that someone committee right you're
questioning their behavior yeah that's
true
that's quite a soft petal though you
know I guess my point is I'm not sure
that I would call rape or alleged rape
and I'm not sure I would call it
questionable bit questionable behavior I
think it's something quite a bit more
serious than that let's stay on the
theme of the Washington Post's being
horrible here's another of their
headlines a headline is a Virginia
preacher believed God can heal anything
then he caught coronavirus yeah and
you're seeing headlines like this all
over the media where you've got you know
so it's so and so believed in God and
then they got coronavirus or so and so
was a protest of the lockdowns and then
got coronavirus so what first of all to
be spiking the football like this is
obviously grotesque and evil but it's
also got nothing to do with anything
yeah the Virginia preacher believed that
God can heal anything then he caught
coronavirus I'm pretty sure if you talk
to the Virginia preacher he still thinks
that God can heal anything this is one
of the problems the media has when they
try to slander and defame Christians
they don't understand Christianity so
they're not very good at doing it you
know Christians who believe as any
Christian does that God can heal
anything that's not the same thing as
thinking that God will heal everything
or that we're all going to be immortal
we don't think that so this is not if
you think the guy
and then you get sick it's not a reason
for a crisis of faith
number five let me read a little bit
from a daily wire report and then we'll
play the video for you but just this
this to give it gives it context it says
on Sunday a 93 year old couple sitting
on folding chairs they had brought to a
beach in Oxnard California got a rude
awakening to the draconian policies
implemented by the state when a
policeman approached them and asked them
to get off the chairs and sit on the
ground
these are 93 year old people sit on the
ground if they wanted to remain where
they were despite the fact that they
were far from any other people the
reasoning of the policeman was that the
folding chairs indicated the couple were
creating a permanent place as opposed to
the temporary nature of sitting on the
sand itself so they were told and I'll
play the video for you now but this this
is the police I've been telling telling
these these these elderly this elderly
couple they have to get off their chairs
and sit on the ground so watch this
[Music]
they're all people
so basically
but they're all people officer yes
because it's much healthier and safer
for 93 year olds to not be sitting on a
chair but be sitting on the ground I
mean the whole thing is first of all how
we're folding chairs I you don't even
know where to begin with this kind of
stuff
how are folding chairs a sign of
permanence a folding chair is permanence
I think a folding chair is a pretty good
sign that it's not permanent you pick up
a folding chair you sit down in it you
get up and you move but why does it
matter how long they're on the beach
this is a very safe place for them to be
in fact they're in the Sun they're in
the open air who cares if they're on the
beach for fifteen hours it makes no dude
that's that's fine I mean it might not
be good for the the heat and everything
in the sun exposure but in terms of the
virus it's a very safe place to be now
we're to go on to your daily cancelation
but before we do a word from our very
good friends aunt Rock auto now if
you're having car trouble right now
rockauto.com is it's a godsend it's and
I would say that it is during any time
even even without all the quarantines
and everything but especially now
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to things like
is your Odyssey in LX or an e^x and then
you have to pretend that you understand
that question and come up with some
answer for it
no rockauto.com you go there it's very
simple very easy to navigate and the
best part for me is that it is very very
affordable the prices are reliably low
so yeah there's no reason to really
price shop you know that whatever you're
seeing on rockauto.com that's the best
price for it
that you're going to find and it's very
convenient you just order it they send
it to you you don't have to leave your
house you don't have to go in you don't
have to deal with all of that Rock Auto
calm amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts that your call car
will ever need at rockauto.com go to
Rock Auto calm right now see all the
parts available for your
our truck right walsh in there how did
you hear about us box so that they know
that we sent you and now for your daily
cancellation listen i really hate to do
this but i have to for the third third
time i think third time total and second
time in a week i have to cancel my wife
and she keeps getting cancelled it hurts
me hurts me more than it hurts her but i
have to have to keep doing it so my wife
is i think i mentioned on the on this
show she recently developed an ambition
to become a chicken farmer and so she
bought a bunch of chickens a few weeks
ago and then she went out to the store
yesterday and came back with more
chickens so she just keeps buying
chickens it's the weirdest compulsion
i've ever seen in a person every time
she comes home now i have to check her
purse to see if she's smuggling more
chickens in because you never know
but yesterday crossed the line because
she came in with these new chickens and
she brought them up to my office right
here in this in this sacred space right
after I'd finished doing the show
actually and she put one of them on my
desk that she had just bought I want you
to take a look at this here's the
picture candid shot there okay so you
notice a few things happening here in
this picture with that chicken first of
all that is the ugliest damn chicken you
will ever see in your life it's it looks
like it's been all up all night smoking
crack is a crack addicted chicken it
looks like some sort of sea urchin mated
with a camel and then their baby mated
with a chicken and this is the chicken
that came out then you also notice my
expression and and it looks in this
picture it looks kind of like I just had
a fight with the chicken and now the
chicken is isn't talking to me is giving
me the cold shoulder and I'm just
sitting there feeling very guilty or
maybe someone said it looks like the
chicken just gave me back bad news and
I'm processing it like maybe the chicken
is my doctor and told me I have six
months to live
frankly I would get a second opinion on
that because you know he's a chicken and
that would be very awkward going to the
second doctor and having to say yeah I
need a second opinion on this diagnosis
why is that well because my first doctor
was a crack-smoking chicken so
anyway and then to make matters worse
I'm talking my wife last night and she
told me that I should be excited about
these new ugly chickens because and
these were her exact words they can do a
dance and bring you sticks I'm sorry
what we're taking care of and feeding
these chickens so they can dance and
bring us sticks okay yeah why don't we
go out next and buy a cow that can
whistle the Happy Birthday song or like
a horse that can moonwalk I mean let's
just fill our whole yard with useless
animals that can do party tricks
what kind of farm are we running here
we're going to be laughingstocks of the
chicken farming community everyone else
is eating omelets made from the eggs
from their chicken and we're over here
watching our chicken tap-dance every
morning so because of all these chickens
that are getting progressively uglier
and more useless my wife is canceled
again I hate to do it but three times
maybe she'll maybe she'll catch the end
let's go to emails and if you become a
daily wire member you can of course
always email the show using the mailbag
so this is from Matt says Matt fellow
Matt here who also wears glasses did you
ever figure out how to use a face mask
and not have your glasses completely fog
up if you get those ones that you have
the material you can pinch at the nose
you can kind of avoid the fogging but
even still it's hard to avoid let me
know what you found out
yeah I in fact I've gotten a lot of I've
got a lot of emails on this I because I
mentioned that this this is one of the
things as a member of the glasses
wearing as a member of the visually
impaired community this is something
that I deal with just more persecution
really and oppression added on to all
the other things so I cope with on a
daily basis so my you know when you wear
the the glass the mask to the store or
something it causes your glasses of fog
up which I which made me very concerned
because now I'm thinking about I never
realised this was an issue and now I'm
thinking about all the sir
and doctors out there who wear glasses
and have and have to wear the facemask
and I'm thinking they can't see a damn
thing apparently during their surgeries
so I've gotten a lot of emails about
this and the consensus seems to be to
use some tape on the inside of the mask
apparently it's as simple as that okay
this is from another mat so we got two
mats since dear Matt Georgia resident
here I don't really have much of a
question so much just to inform you your
listeners and Watchers about opening day
I know there's been a lot of hate thrown
at governor Kemp after his announcement
that Georgia was opening certain aspects
of the economy my wife and I more out of
genuine curiosity decided to go out and
see how this was working for restaurants
as much as people want to believe that
all the restaurants were just given the
green lights open completely
that's just plain misinformation we had
to go to three separate restaurants they
were still serving curbside and delivery
but they weren't conducting dining in
service I asked them why they weren't
open for dine in and their answer made
perfect sense to us
the employee explained that they were
planning to open the following Monday
but they're still going through
procedural changes in training my wife
and I did manage to find a place that
was serving dining to set the scene the
hosts when we walked in asked in a
respectful way for us to please keep our
distance from the host station I told
him how many people were in my party we
had five and he told us that it was
going to be a 10-minute wait and okay a
lot of a lot of detail here a lot of
tangential detail so what are the actual
well we finally sat our waitress was
dressed in protective wear masks and
gloves she maintained her distance from
our table while she got our orders the
layout of the restaurant was in such a
way that it made sense there was ample
room and you could tell that it was well
thought out we were given paper menus
the tables were bare no salt and pepper
shakers and the mustard ketchup bottles
if he needed salt or pepper they bring
you individually wrapped salt or pepper
for your table if you want ketchup
mustard they would get you a glass cup
and the ketchup or mustard and filled a
cup of your table I believe this is to
assure that people will see that it
wasn't just sitting in a refrigerator
and okay so I was curious what the what
the restaurants look like now post
Corona
and at least in this one case that's
what they're doing now you know yeah I'm
glad they opened up in in Georgia and
many states now are supposedly starting
the process of reopening I was just
reading about Texas and they're gonna
start opening stuff up but in Texas and
it's like this in other states too in
Texas in phase one of the reopening
restaurants have to operate at 25%
capacity for dining and I'm just
thinking something like that you know
yes I suppose we could say it's better
than nothing but is it really because if
you only have 25 percent capacity for
dining I think a lot of restaurants are
gonna say it's not financially worth it
to do that because that means we got to
bring in more staff and pay them to wait
the tables and we can only have 25
percent of our normal amount of
customers and I just I think what we
have to watch out for is there's gonna
be states that supposedly are reopening
and I'm not saying this is the case with
Texas but there are gonna be states that
are reopening quote-unquote but in
reality are not they're just saying it
but but the the guidelines and rules put
in place are so onerous that it makes it
impossible for a lot of businesses to
actually open and I think that they're
gonna make this way more complicated
than it needs to be okay yeah I'm not
saying we go back to life completely as
normal but we don't need to have you
don't need to have a Bible length book
of rules telling businesses what to do I
think most of it is pretty obvious yeah
okay wear gloves if you're in the food
industry maybe wear a mask that makes
sense if especially if you're in the
food industry you don't want to put
people right on top of each other
doesn't need to be 25% capacity I think
just really basic common sense
precautions are what's necessary people
for the most part are reasonable you
know I've been out plenty during this
whole thing not that I can go that many
places but at least to the store over
the weekend we went as a family we went
for a hike you know
just at a local park and it was very
busy you know there's tons of people
there because everyone's itching to get
out of the house like we were and some
of the trails we were walking on were
pretty pretty narrow and but we didn't
need a set of rules to tell us what to
do
it was just okay you keep walking on the
narrow path there's another group of
people coming the opposite direction one
of you just moves over and lets the
other group pass that's the amazing
thing we didn't need any guidelines or
rules we didn't need the federal
government to tell us what to do if we
encounter people on the trail we already
know just okay you move already getting
some space so we don't need to make it
more complicated than needs to be okay
this is from Mark says Matt I'm
wondering when you will admit you were
wrong about the lockdowns almost 60,000
dead obviously the lock downs were and
are necessary it's embarrassing that you
still continue to downplay it I've lost
so much respect for you well mark don't
take this the wrong way but I don't
really care if you respect me or not
that's of no concern to me
I find it interesting that you assume
60,000 dead proves our mitigation
strategy was successful that's kind of
an odd assumption isn't it you're saying
look at all these people who died
obviously what we did to stop people
from dying worked see this is what
you've done over on the pro lockdown
side you've set up a heads I win tails
you lose situation where no matter what
no matter what the data shows no matter
how many people die or don't die it
proves that the lockdowns were needed
but I'd say the data proves the opposite
these antibody tests indicate that the
virus is as I said the beginning show
way more widely spread than we were told
which means that by the time the
lockdown started it had already made its
way through many communities which means
that you were locking people who had the
virus or had already been exposed to it
into their homes with family members
often older family members who didn't
have it creating exactly the right kind
of scenario for transmission of the
virus not the right scenario to avoid
getting it but the right scenario for
transmitting it prolonged indoor closed
quarters contact with family members
that's how this this thing primarily
spreads and these lock downs created the
perfect situation for that and aside
from all that 30 million unemployed 150
million
at risk of starvation says the UN flute
food supply chain catastrophic ly
disrupted civil liberties abolished you
look at all of this and your conclusion
is that the government did the right
thing really that's your conclusion you
think all of this somehow proves me
wrong no I don't I don't think that's I
don't think that's the case at all
but I appreciate the the email and
thanks everybody for watching we will
leave it there
god bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 as more and more people
around the country get arrested for
leaving their homes as we approach the
45th day since President Trump told us
to hunker down for 15 days to slow the
spread some people are beginning to
wonder if these lockdowns are destroying
our Liberty unfortunately our liberty
problems run a lot deeper than being
locked in your house for a few weeks and
both sides of the aisle are to blame
then more evidence emerges that Joe
Biden got handsy with a staffer in the
90s as the mainstream media steadfastly
and courageously refused to ask him
about the government confirms the
existence of UFOs okay and Nancy Pelosi
wants to bribe you with your own money
all that and more check it out on the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]